大丈夫だからみんな見たと思うけど、
この風刺的な日本の
コンビニエンスストアの運搬ビデオがあっ
て、この男はバンドエイド
と卵サラダがお茶や
その他のものを挟んでいるようだ。
これはどこでも手に入るかもしれませんが
、日本で買えば素晴らしいです。なぜなら
日本はとても面白いからです。
その前提は私にはうまくいきません。
それは
、卵サラダサンドイッチを試してみるように、すべてのものは日本の方が優れているからです。
私は
日本について多くの肯定
的な
ことを言っていますが、それは日本について肯定的なことしか言わ
ないからです.存在すらしていない問題について話すことはできません. 私が言わ
ないことを言うのは
、日本人のことをよく知っているから
です 動機があるからで
はなく、自分が何を考えているのかさえわからないからではありません
彼がいたこと
日本の伝統的なコンビニエンス ストア
文化をからかう彼は絶対
に謝罪しないので、私は日本に行きます。申し訳
ありませんが、この男にはもう 1 つ、豊かな要素を軽視し
ている場合にのみここで楽しい時間を過ごすことができるかどうかなど
です。
文化の中で、あなたは明らかにまだ
後方の外国のバブルにいるので
、バッグを整理して家に帰りましょう。日本
はあなたがここにいることを望んでいません。
このビデオを肯定的なメモで終了してください 日本が好きならこのビデオを高く評価してください
日本が
好きならチャンネル登録してください 日本のいいねとサブスク
を取得できます
か 大丈夫です クールで次の
ビデオでは、
伝統的な日本の西洋コーヒーに行くことができます
素晴らしいサウンドのショップ 私はもう元気
です ここでビデオを終了しますが、
すぐにまたお話しします
さよなら
ありがとう
毎回
より簡単なお金